à à
ừ ừ
Em à mình mới đổi mình mới đổi à xanh độ
trễ nó bình luận Bây giờ nó sẽ
anh bình bình luận Bây giờ nó sẽ cậu
chậm hơn rất nhiều nha
về chất lượng mà sẽ cải thiện
Ừ chắc là được đấy
anh thấy mưa sao chưa thấy nét không ạ
anh mưa rồi đúng không nghe Bây giờ thì
có độ trễ nó tăng lên rồi thì nên thành
ra là
khi các bạn nhắn tin gì cho người đến
tầm 56 phút sau có gì thế không biết
được thì mình mới thấy được cái tin nhắn
cho nên là cái này Thực ra nó cũng là
nhược điểm của kìa mình mình từng thấy
một vài truy mơ kiểu à
I kiểu nó hơi bị phốt một tí cho kẹo
trò chuyện một loạt spam bình luận là là
cảnh báo chuyên mơ nhờ chưa Mơ một lúc
sau nhìn thấy
anh đi đây này là delay cả giọng nói của
mình với hình ảnh hay như nào hay chỉ
đơn giản đã delay so với bình luận thôi
nha các bạn nghe với hình ảnh cha vẫn
được đúng không
ừ ừ
chỉ tạm chấp nhận các bạn sẽ học và chủ
yếu tập trung vào màn hình mạnh nhất ở
Ừ ok ở chỗ nào hôm nay mình bắt đầu buổi
họp nha hơi muộn muộn một tí thôi
thì hôm nay mình sẽ học à
Ờ Ờ cái này Thực ra là
Ừ mình đang dịch ra tiếng Việt nó hơi bị
thô và mình cho biết từ như nào mình tra
Google nó toàn ra tiếng Anh thôi nên
mình tạm gọi này như thế này Đó là hàm
nhóm tứ ca liên quan hôm nay mình sẽ
dbow và thống kê thời gian thống kê này
là liên quan đến những cái ha môi trước
mình đã học những kết hợp với cả hôm nay
nó sẽ liên quan dụ là lấy ra mới nhất
này ra cũng ngất này Hà chỉ lấy ra 5 bạn
26 bạn thì gì đấy
thì
mình có tổng hợp lại câu hỏi của hai
buổi 2 buổi hôm trước để mà hôm nay mình
trả lời nhanh này à
à à Học làm web web gà hôm trước mình
từng nói các bạn hạn chế gỗ ép thì viết
như này nhá đổi hơi cơ bản
rất công nghệ thông tin đó là mình nên
sửa ngay Mình lỗi chính tả ở nhà không
Mất mặt lắm
bắt buộc phải học file không chỉ ra thế
thì thực ra các bạn không cần phải học
bắt buộc cái gì cái phần em
ờ ờ nếu mà các bạn chỉ cần làm bác em họ
thậm chí cả các bạn học chuyên vé queo
rồi thì các bạn không cần phải học ngôn
ngữ lập trình cũng được nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà thực tế thì các bạn biết một
chút để mà làm lúc đầu làm cả hai làm từ
đầu đến cuối một cái trang web tự bản
thân mình làm đấy thì nó sẽ ổn hơn
có cách nào để con bớt từ máy kia xanh
espresso với Nhanh không thì cái này
chính cặp chứ bạn này đã nói những từ
khóa để mà cha Oh rồi nó Converse máy
quay out to SQL Server mình tra thử nhé
này từ Apple Server này đó rõ ra những
cái tool hoặc à những cách để bán
convert xong rồi Đương nhiên là mình
nghĩ là đương nhiên nó cũng sẽ có nó tun
công cụ thì nó có thể là Ừ nó chỉ hỗ trợ
những cái bài Toán phổ biến trên nó
không hỗ trợ những bài toán mà phức tạp
theo kiểu đó giờ dài dòng thì cho là
mình nghĩ là cái tôi này không thể hỗ
trợ được
ừ ừ
Xe Tăng 2 lần thì như bị tương tác với
đi vậy thấy có mỗi 80 mấy ông hay là
chắc à Mấy ông toàn ngồi xem lại hết rồi
nhé Tự nhiên càng ngày lượng sinh viên
lại càng giảm dần Không biết là mình có
gì sai sai đấy không
ừ ừ
Ừ anh đến Tuyết là như thế nào ạ Thì
thực tế là trường mình dậy à người lập
trình đưa nghe nó sẽ dạy cả từ HP pro CS
này cho đến ngôn ngữ lập trình c xong
rồi TP này ra va nữa và nhưng có cả SQL
thì à
Ừ nhưng mà như vậy Nãy Nhưng có nói đó
là thôi mình đi học ra mình không quan
tâm mấy cái này lắm lúc mà mình đi làm
thì mình quan tâm hơn cũng như là về sau
mình quay lại đi dậy
người sau mình quay lại đi dạy thì mình
thấy aquare phải thực sự hai đều mà dậy
dậy hay ân hận so với bên ngôn ngữ lập
trình
ừ ừ
cho anh Anh Mình mình có gắn link mà à
Xin lỗi Xin lỗi Xin lỗi
họ đậu xanh
à à
Ừ mình vừa nãy mình xóa cái bình luận cũ
à À rồi rồi
à à
thì các bạn mượt hơn rồi nó không bị nát
nữa đúng không Ok Ok
à à
thì tại sao không khai bào 30kg ngay tại
cột đó mới để ở dưới cái này thì mình
mình vài bài học luôn à mình xem qua về
cái vụ hôm trước mình có bảo các bạn thử
tìm hiểu trả lời câu này nhá đi
xe máy queo thì nó sẽ khác SQL Server
một vài chỗ thôi
Thế thì nên là thì nên là anh Nghĩa à
anh anh được tiên thì bây giờ để mà anh
đi tìm điểm khác biệt giữa các hơi khó
cách tốt thì có thể là anh cứ thành cái
anh cứ từ chạy thử thấy cái đoạn nào lỗi
thì
Ừ anh nó sẽ báo cảnh báo lỗi tại cái chỗ
đói thì anh anh chỉ cần là
à à Tra Google là ví dụ là ví dụ nó cạnh
thì báo lỗi Tại thằng in entity vì thằng
trong máy Ware thì không phải lên Titi
mà nó autoincrement được ạ thì mình chỉ
cần cha ví dụ được mình chai indentity
này
tu à Máy kia chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ hiển
thị luôn là auto increment này đánh chưa
thấy thì mình biết mà mình đổi lại
bác Đợi tí ăn cho no mà nó bên pha nhà
con cho nó thường ai kiểu mở file mà
nghỉ hai đều gãy I
khi các con trùm report chưa Đợi mình tí
lên mình Mở cái file cũ
Ừ
anh mở chữa lại phải cũng ah
cái file đâu mất rồi
em không có nào forex nữa rồi
I Knew đ
xe Open em mỗi khi mình ở nấu tin được
mà
ăn cơm cho nó ăn chỗ nó bình thường mỗi
khi vẫn được mình ạ
nhạc karaoke ok
thì à ở đây hôm trước mình có hỏi cái
câu đó là tại sao
thì các bạn lại để file Mickey ở dưới
cho dù rõ ràng các bạn thì khai báo ngay
trên này
như thế này à
Ừ thì có bạn nói là để cho nó trực quan
cũng cũng là một tí nhưng thực ra thực
tế cái này nó còn chưa quan hơn cho khai
báo ở dưới và cũng như là có bạn bảo là
để cho dãy sửa thứ cũng cũng không hẳn
là sai nhưng mà cũng có bạn bình luận
ngay ở dưới đó là choi minki là
về sau nó sẽ cố định thường anh không
đổi thế nên là cũng không có trường hợp
mà về sau mình sửa file Mickey cái Rốt
cuộc Tại sao wiki để cuối như thế này
thực kế nó đơn giản thôi
hôm trước mình có hỏi ở trong
ừ ừ
nhà
mình có hỏi ở trong cái câu trắc nghiệm
đó là triky thì nó là duy nhất một bảng
chỉ có mụn khóa chính đúng không Nhưng
có một khóa trinh đấy có thể chứa nhiều
cột chưa Chính xác là nếu màn theo dịch
ra À ấy và nó cậu dịch thôi nó không
phải là cụt nữa mà nó là trường giá trị
toàn bộ những cái này không là cụt mà nó
thường giá trị thì một quá trình có thể
chứa nhiều
thị trường giá trị chưa tất cả xa ví dụ
là do sửa mình hoàn toàn thể vừa làm mã
vừa họ tên như này được nghĩa là cả hai
cái này cùng Đọc khóa chính và cả hai
cái này không được phép cùng lắp kiểu
cầu Thế thì mình sẽ áp dụng cái đấy
trong những trường hợp nào có chính hung
sau mình sẽ hợp với khóa ngoại mình học
về tách ra bảo ngày các thứ thì mình sẽ
nói cụ thể hơn về vụ là một khóa chính
chứa nhiều cột là như thế nào
Khi nào nào vừa nói xong không được nói
tạo nhiều hoa chính nhá nhiều phải chính
là chữ thầy dạy chay thay đấy Không nói
chuyện là nhiều khóa chính được chưa một
bà chỉ có một quá trình thôi Mà một khóa
chính Đấy chứa nhiều cột chưa Hãy dùng
từ giá chuẩn nhé không đi phỏng vấn nó
nói cô ấy bị loại luôn vòng gửi xe đấy Ờ
khi dùng Aspirin nofer cho toàn bộ ứng
dụng được không Cái này tương tự gần như
là câu hỏi các vào dùm em QR cho toàn bộ
ứng dụng được không Cái bài toán nowhere
nó vừa nãy mình khó nói qua một tí đó
nói que vì là tốt nó tiện nó nhanh hơn
so với queo nó hợp phù hợp cho những dự
án rất là lớn theo kiểu là thứ nhất là
theo kiểu free time là theo thời gian
thực thì bắt buộc cả không cần nên at
work kiểm tra về cái độ chặt chẽ của dữ
liệu
anh cũng như là Nokia thì phù hợp cho
cái lưu lại ở trong một bảng có triệu
hai hàng tỉ dữ liệu thì mình không thể
Cứ mỗi lần mí do ta update thì mình lại
ngồi kiểm tra xem nó tránh trùng được
không cả bởi vì nó sẽ rất nặng và sẽ rất
là lâu thì nên là phù hợp cho nó ghét
wear.con lệnh Nếu thấy ngược lại là gì
Apple lại phù hợp cho những cái bài toán
mà các bạn là bài toán mà thực ra nó
không lên lấy một triệu bản ghi các bạn
không cần làm theo thời gian thực mà các
bạn muốn độ chính xác rất là cao mà thì
các bạn sẽ dùng iCloud giản thế thôi
Ở
đây có một bạn hôm trước có khuyên mình
đấy này Thực tế là
Ừ cái này nhà A ông ấy khuyến khích các
bạn với tệ tạo tên mạng hay tên cột thậm
chí bằng tiếng Anh đúng không tránh được
thói quen xấu xấu về sau này hồi trước
mình từng cạnh tranh cãi với 11 một
người vào trong người câu lạc bộ của
mình mình có khuyên sinh viên mình đúng
kiểu nhà luôn đó là các bạn nên đặt tên
biến là bằng tiếng Anh thì nó sẽ tốt Nó
sẽ kiểu nó sẽ tránh bị mông lung nhưng
mà chả đùa
bởi vì tiếng Việt mình nó kéo đôi khi nó
cứ bị Hơi hơi bị rừng già quá nó kiểu
chi tiết quá nhưng mà cũng Dương ra từ
tiếng Anh thì nó có đúng rồi còn những
cái từ nó chuyên ngành để mà chuyên tả
về cái đấy nhận sự ngắn gọn và dễ hiểu
hơn bởi tiếng Việt không có dấu ở nóng
cái phạm trù gì đó khó lắm
thì có ông vào phần mác Ông ấy bảo là
tại sao mày tiếng Anh mà tính khác hay
gì đấy kết hợp với việc đã là cái đặt
tên biến thì nó cũng Anh văn văn
thực tế các bạn nên đề bằng tiếng Anh
chỉ vì tiếng Anh của nó vốn là nó có
chuyên ngành rồi thì các bạn kiểu nên
thống nhất như thế thậm chí đương nhiên
có những từ tiếng Anh đồng nghĩa nhưng
mà đến một công ty thường là giống như
mình vào cái công ty bên A thương mại
điện tử này nó bắt buộc phải có những từ
chuyên ngành của những cái từ thương mại
từ đấy Và thậm chí ở bọn mình phải quy
ước với nhau đó là mình chỉ dùng tên
biển nó như này như kia để tránh việc cả
kiểu mình kiểu ông này thì đặt tên kiểu
này ông này là tên cũ Kia đúng không
Nhưng mà lúc mới dậy cho các bạn như này
thì các bạn còn đang đỡ bỡ ngỡ và mình
tin là có nhiều bạn ở đây Rộng chữa
tiếng Anh buồn tiếng Anh không hoàn là
tốt lắm nên là mình mới đang dạy hết
bằng tiếng Việt tự nhiên là về sau về
sau cái gì mình cũng sẽ bắt các bạn phải
trao Google của mình anh này đặt tự đặt
mọi thứ bằng tiếng Anh các những thứ chỉ
cho quen cũng không hoàn là khó lắm đâu
bởi du lịch mình sẽ mình sẽ giải giải
thích nói chung dịch hộ các bạn mà chỉ
có bạn chỉ cần làm theo thế được
anh
à nếu mình đặt n Vespa 50 mà nhập hơn 50
ký tự theo ca có bạn trả lời ngay dưới
lấy rồi Nhưng mình muốn trả lời luôn cho
những bạn nào còn thắc mắc đó là nếu mà
các bạn đặt như này sau đó các bạn Nhập
hơn 59 tự thì nó sẽ cắt đi nó sẽ chỉ còn
đúng 50 ký tự cho các bạn thôi nó khác
với ngôn ngữ lập trình ngôn ngữ lập
trình các bạn sẽ khai báo kiểu nghe được
Nhưng mà nếu mà các bạn Nhập tối đa lớn
hơn thì nó sẽ bị thông báo lỗi
Ừ nó bị như thế anh ơi làm sao để mình
lấy khách hàng
Khi dòng thứ n trong bảng dai cái thứ mà
hôm nay mình sẽ học là mình sẽ có khái
niệm là bỏ qua bao nhiêu bạn thì lấy bao
nhiêu bạn nặng ạ ạ
Ở đây có cách nào là khắc phục không anh
kiểu bởi vì hôm trước mình còn nói về
cái vụ là thằng máy quý ông ấy thì nó
khi mà lấy theo tên thanhhhh hè thành
thì nó lại biển anh không phân biệt có
dấu cái này thì à
Anh
Đào Thị mình tra thử nhé tất cả mình
cũng chưa tra cái câu này đâu
chung kết
đầu tiên là wei-mo mai que này
sẽ chuyện này Unicode ạ
a
value gì Chắc mày ạ
à à
cho thuê xe Transit ngày ngon
a cho xét này để mở lưu lại ngôn ngữ mà
các bạn sẽ
chị
sẽ dùng chào sao
Chị xem ở đây kawaya gì đó không
Anh có ở đây nó không để cập
anh ở đây có cái khái niệm có này mình
đĩa con rết này sẽ được Đấy mình tăng dù
con rết này order Bike Hôm trước mình
còn nhắc qua về cái vụ là Anh
tên Đức có chữ đời ấy còn tồn tại trong
bảng chữ cái
là tinh ấy nên thành ra là nó sắp xếp nó
bị sai hoặc là tên tên tiếng Việt có dấu
ý thì nó sẽ sắp xếp chung cuối của bạn
chữ cái bởi vì nó không nằm trong bảng
Latinh thì các bạn sẽ phải dùng cái crit
này để mà sắp xếp nó theo tiếng Việt cho
chuột ảnh kiểu thế
thì mình nghĩ là chắc là were theo cái
này chắc cũng được Hình như thế
Hôm nay tôi đã có ông không bao giờ nên
sử dụng utf-8 trong máy que rồi
Chả liên quan hệ mai qua em à phải là
utf-8
MP4
cái khi nào mình dậy Xanh Mãi với ai thì
mình sẽ giải thích của mình cái vụ này
nhé
trong yêu tim ai là người toàn diện nhất
vậy thầy
Ừ cái cái này mình chưa ghe 8 giờ mình
phải dậy rồi cho mình mình có nên là
mình cái câu này cho mình đến cuối buổi
nhé
cô
dạy kỹ năng cho Google cái này cuối bởi
luôn đi
mình có thể mình sẽ hướng dẫn về cả
claire trong khóa này không ngoan lại
khóa máy ảnh mà chính xác là mình sẽ
hướng dẫn mình sẽ dậy để vào em có thể
lúc đấy được biết độ Đông sinh viên hơn
Bởi vì thực ra có nhiều người đã đi làm
ở trong trong mình trong kênh của mình
mà toàn Thiên Tài ẩn danh thôi
Ừ cái này thì ạ Chắc là bạn mình khuyên
các bạn nên tra Google Nhưng mà theo
mình thì nó cũng có nhiều nét tương độc
Bởi vì mình không làm thì cả hai ngày
này Đây là có những cái câu ấy các bạn
hoàn toàn hệ cha nó Nó kiểu như thế này
trúng không
với sẽ vs a xong các bạn sẽ thấy việc là
con sẽ kiểu so sánh so sánh như thế nào
à à
ở đây mình có nốt lại ở đây cho bản thân
mình thôi đó là đôi khi có những cái tra
đấy Mình chưa kịp trả lời hoặc cả
mình mình trả lời rồi nhưng có vài bạn
góp ý ở trả lời cho em Trả lại trong cả
kênh ngày nữa là các bạn trả lời đi giúp
đỡ các bạn khác thì ra hồi mình đi học
cũng thế Mình mình giúp đỡ các bạn khác
rất nhiều nên à Tự Nhiên trình độ của
mình cải thiện rất nhiều cũng như là
mình biết cách để mà dậy dậy người khác
kiểu thế Thành A Thầy mình thấy mình
cũng có kỹ năng dạy là mấy cho mình đi
dạy học kết hợp việc là khi mà
em chọc đôi khi các bạn hiểu một vấn đề
Để mà giải thích cho một người khác đi
thì trình độ các bạn phải lên rất nhiều
thế nên là cái đấy còn nhiều là tự ép
bản thân này bạn thân mình giỏi hơn đấy
Thế là mình khuyên các bạn là
các bạn ngoài việc các bạn tự tự phấn
đấu tự trau dồi vào kiến thức cho bản
thân mình để cho mình hiểu thì có một
cách nữa đó là các bạn đi Trả lời câu
hỏi người khác thì cả sẽ bạn thân mình
thấy cách đấy rất là phù hợp với rất
nhiều người luôn ấy rất nhiều người cậu
lên những cái dự các bạn thấy có rất
nhiều diễn đàn về hỏi đáp trên hình về
bên công nghệ thông tin này có cái sách
đâu lâu rồi ạ Đấy bản thân toàn bộ những
người này có thể là chưa chưa biết câu
trả lời ngay lúc đấy nhưng mà đều tra
Google và đều tự mày mò để mà tìm cách
sạch giải quyết bài toán trả lời câu hỏi
cho người ta và tự nhiên trình của họ
lên rất cao và họ lại tự anh cũng và
năng nổ hơn tự nhiên lại đam mê hơn bởi
vì cái cảm giác giúp được cho người khác
rất vui ngày khác Cảm ơn mình mình cảm
thấy cũng có gì đó thấy vui nữa
ở đỉnh cảm ơn bằng tiền là được mình tải
về vật chất thì mình lại không thích ở
Ở đây có bạn hỏi câu này cũng
À hôm trước là mình nhớ cái bài toán là
mình có kiểm tra là It's not luôn là để
lấy ra tất cả những cái bạn mà có điểm
đấy đúng không Bạn ấy bảo là mình kiểm
tra điểm lớn hơn bằng 0 được không Thực
ra là trong trường hợp này vẫn nhận vẫn
chạy được không Bởi vì rõ ràng là điểm
của mình đang nằm trong bé
thế giới hạn từ 0 đến 10 và đúng là luôn
Nếu mà nôn thì không thể nào mã lớn nó
bạn không được Nãy có một tí cũng khá
hay nếu mà bạn nào chưa biết về ít nó
luôn Nhưng mà việc so sánh như này thì
ra nó không tốt bằng nghĩ nó nôn Và đôi
khi là sẽ sai ví dụ lần sử trong trường
hợp này không phải là số nữa là trong
trường hợp là chuỗi là Nhạn thì các bạn
so sánh cái này thì không biết So sánh
nào sâu xanh với chuỗi rỗng mà nó không
đúng
anh ở đây có bạn hôm trước góp ý Minh
dịch vụ là không biết là góp ý không
Theo mình thì nó sẽ giữ góp ý đó là
anh đánh máy nhanh cốt không theo nhưng
mà có thể là à
A gọi mình mình nốt ở đây vụ này vì mình
định nói qua các bạn thì nhất à các bạn
cũng nên gõ mảnh nhanh một tí bởi vì
mình thấy nhiều bạn thì ra gõ mày cũng
cũng không không nhanh lắm Thực ra nó
ảnh hưởng thứ nhất à hiệu quả công việc
đúng không năng suất các thứ cũng như là
các bạn sẽ bị lừa
Ý mình nói là các bạn sẽ bị lười đi kẻo
lại có nhiều cái đoạn mà kiểu các bạn
hãy nó bị dài quá giống như làm bài tập
cùng mình các bạn đôi khi thấy bài tập
của mình nó thể lên đến gần trăm dòng
thậm chí hơn trăm dòng các bạn gõ chậm
thì sẽ nghĩ rằng à buổi là bài này mình
mới gõ cho hơn Tiếm thì các bạn sẽ bị
lạc thì các bạn phải phải làm mất cái
suy nghĩ thì đi bằng các bạn Luyện gõ nó
ngon thứ nhất là hồi trước mình thường
ai bảo đó là một là các bạn lên trang
theo phạm ạ
à Thèm phem single này đúng không luyện
gỗ Bình thường anh lên để luyện gõ này
nó có phiên bản tiếng Việt hoặc tiếng
Anh mình chưa quen gõ tiếng Anh thì mình
gõ tiếng Việt thôi tại mình thấy lượng
gõ trên này
cái Luyện gõ trên này thì vào nhà nghỉ à
khi mình gõ được cũng tầm 90 từ một phút
đấy Căng nhất là như thế thì các bạn
cũng không cần phải nhớ Thiên như thế
các bạn chỉ cần nên gõ tầm đền á á
ờ ờ thường là 60 từ 1 phút là rất là ổn
rồi
à à
U60 từ một phút tất cả một giây một từ
thì rất là ổn rồi sẽ được các bạn đừng
nên gọi chậm quá bởi vì thứ nhất à nhưng
mình nói giảm hiệu suất đúng không Thứ
Hai thật trông nó không ngầu kiểu gì thế
vì thực bởi vì a các bạn vì sau gõ gõ mà
tự như cứ phải cúi xuống nhìn bàn phím
Ngạn này Các rỡ thứ từ ra nó không ngầu
nhưng mà trừ khi thực ra thì nói thế
không phải để các bạn tự ti đâu vì thực
tế đó Cái người thầy của mình hôi trước
mình từng nói ngày anh thấy mà cứ nhanh
lên phim Bất Hủ để cho các bạn hãy nhớ
đúng không thìa
canh Face đấy Anh thấy gỗ máy ra chậm
luôn và thượng chỉ là con nhìn xuống hả
mắn phím mì gõ cơ nhưng mà anh đấy gõ
cốt để đâu chắc nhìn đấy nên làm thực ra
chẳng có ý kiến gì cả vì anh ấy gõ chậm
nữa
anh không nhanh nhậu đong ấy kiểu đấy
nên là anh ấy vẫn ngầu trong mắt mình
nhưng thực sự thì gõ nhanh trông ngầu
hơn mà đúng không ạ
à à Ừ cái ghét bếp này
anh làm Em định lấy ngày tháng thôi
không nhận định phần tham được không ạ
Đây cái mà hôm nay mình sẽ chữa bài tập
luôn này gì tí mình chữa mình sẽ trả lời
trong e có sử dụng được vào làm không
Anh thực ra mãi về sau mình mò được Đúng
là anh theo nó vừa gọi ít theo này vừa
vòng lặp này thậm chí vừa có cả khai báo
biến nên là mình thấy à iCloud bây giờ
nó nhanh mà ngôn ngữ lập trình mới dồi
vì ngôn ngữ lập trình thực ra nó cũng
chỉ có những cái điều đấy thôi
Ừ
thì mình nghĩa là ở các bạn học em queo
này xong sang bên ngôn ngữ lập trình
thật chứa sẽ dễ hiểu
Ừ cái đít tuần nào mày biết xảy ra đây
Ờ Ờ
cái này thờ ra là có nhiều câu thì mình
nghĩ là các bạn nên tự chiêm nghiệm tự
chạy thương thay vì họp cũng cũng là một
cái để mà tự học đúng không nghe mình
trả lời nhanh ở đây là không
piston là lọc Chung đấy Cái vụ ông chưa
Mình nói về lập chung ấy ra nó mình thử
mình cũng phải thử lại luôn lúc đấy Và
kết quả là không nó không để lọc Trùng 2
cột cùng lúc
đây hôm nay mình nhớ mình hứa các bạn về
cái vụ hết không cha đến cuối cuối buổi
nhé các bạn Nhớ nhắc mình nhé Và thậm
chí cuối buổi mà có ông làm mà rời đi
thì càng tốt cho ngon tôi sẽ nhắc vụ
khách khủng rau cùng cho mấy ông thấy
hối hận
ai Hôm trước mình có mình có trả lại thì
nó là khái niệm kham.tam Minh Attack
Attack ở tấn công mà nó nó không nhắc
ngay hậu gì đây cả nhưng mà tên này
khẳng định việc liên quan đến thăm Minh
là là thôi gian đúng không là đo lường
thời gian để tấn công thì các bạn trai
ngay từ tiêu đề này nó sự ra luôn bài
đăng đấy các bạn thì đọc trước nhưng mà
có thể các bạn sẽ thấy hơn mông lung khó
hiểu thì để tí mình khử nó lại theo ý
hiểu của mình thì bạn sẽ thấy nó hay như
thế nào
Hôm trước mình có nói vụ là tách tên ra
tất cả họ cả tên ra đúng không tay mình
thức mở lại các bạn đấy
kìa ra sự
dự án xử tên là sử các họ tên là mẹ năm
đấy ạ thì tách tên ra bởi dấu phẩy do
cách thì bạn ấy bảo dùng gạch được không
Nếu bạn trai với gạch thì nó sẽ không
phải ngôn ngữ lập trình thời gian nó
biết nó còn la la giống như em quen
thằng Tí Nó kiểu nó liên quan đến việc à
truy vấn và truy vấn và kiểu lọc dữ liệu
nhưng mà
có bạn trả lời ngay dưới đấy gạch là bài
toán rất là khó thực ra là càng tìm hiểu
nó cái mông lưu thì đúng cách này rất là
nhằm à có những hạn chế giống với cách
này bởi vì thực ra nó còn liên quan đến
tốc độ nữa à
Ừ ừ
em hai năm tránh ảnh giờ muốn quay lại
IP thì nên làm gì chứ sắc là các bạn nên
nên học gì học học gì và cảm thấy cái gì
phù hợp rồi mình làm thôi đúng không À
và thực ra là các bạn học cái ngành này
như mình đã nói từ các bạn không nên
quan tâm tại bộ quan tâm về tuổi tác hay
á các thứ thứ thì mình mình cũng không
không nên so sánh bạn thân mình phải bất
kỳ ai mà đúng không nghỉ ngơi số sàng
với chính mình đó là mình sau vài tháng
mà mình không mang họ thêm được gì thì
mình cho mình cũng nên xem lại đúng
không có gì Nó không phù hợp với mình
thật hay à mình không tìm được đúng
người để mà dậy mình 2 á Gì gì đó
Ừ ừ cách viết CV chắc là nhà mình hôm
nay có khi là bây giờ bị Hơi bị quá đi
ra rồi này chắc hôm nay cũng không không
hướng dẫn các bạn về vụ VC được Chắc lại
nợ bụi khác nữa nhé ạ
Ừ cái này Trả Lời Một Câu Hỏi thì bây
giờ đến lượt Chữa bài tập nhạc không lời
hay quá Bộ mày không không biết được bộ
của mày nó sẽ lên hơn 2 tiếng mất
sẽ mở bài tập lên thì chữa nhé
Chiều cao là bài tập này số kết hợp buổi
hôm nay thư da là cũng phải dựa vào cái
bài này mình mình thường hay làm bài tập
dễ mà bộ máy để dùng lại mà không ạ
à à
anh
ấy Mình đã cố viết bài tập theo kiểu
dạng là là nó là một cái giống như một
vài giá thực tế thì các bạn đọc về đỡ bị
kiểu Cảm thấy nhàm chán không ăn thực tế
rồi Như này xét và chẳng biết được và
các bạn cần phải lưu ý gì cả thì cái
mình có ghi thêm một vài điều kiện ở đây
là nó cũng tương đối màu cho các bạn để
các bạn biết phải lưu gì rồi thực tế
không mấy cái này hiền nhiên là dụ là
không được xét chung rồi cái nhiên có
này hay là nguyên lương là phải số dương
là chỉ nhiên có này hay gì đó đúng không
ngày à tất cả cô không được để trống này
chẳng hạn đúng không
tiên nên mình cứ trả bạn đúng không Thì
tao mạng là
bạn kết với bồ nhân viên em ạ
mã pin thì đem tt rồi à
vì
sao mình lại thích ăn nữa à
Anh tên là ngon
tên ở
đây mình có nhắc đến tuổi phải ra các
bạn ốp luôn tôi mà các bạn không nên đọc
nên cuối
ừ ừ
a
beautiful CPU và Phong Trần Thế chắc ạ
Bạn phải đợi hình tầm phải 56 buổi nữa
là ít
các bạn hãy cho vào hơi sớm à
Ừ thì các bạn thấy ở đây rõ ràng mà mình
có đề cập liên quan đến thứ nhất là xinh
tháng này nhìn nó sẽ không thể các bạn
lưu lại tuổi Thứ hai là hôm trước mình
em hỏi qua các bạn là các bạn hạn chế
nên lưu tuổi bởi vì ạ Các bạn lưu tuổi
xong thì sang năm thì các bạn lại Mất
công cập nhật lại tuổi thì thấy không
tốt các bạn luôn lưu này xinh thôi à
vợ chồng ơi hôm sau chắc chắn nó sẽ phải
nói quay Mickey và full key anh cũng hết
thứ để mà tránh ra rồi mua
giới tính này là là bit chẳng hạn đúng
không Thì mà để khô là nữ thì tra để tôi
là không nặng không
từ
ngày vào là này
là đến này
là ghét Tết là mặc gì ra hôm nay đúng
không ạ
có nghề nghiệp chọn là kiểu bởi vì để
chữ và có dấu đúng không Thì sẽ là nấu
phải tra là ạ mà đến 50 Thực ra thoải
mái rồi
tất cả cột không để chống cái nón luôn
nôn nôn nôn này à
à à
ạ sau khi mà các bạn làm xong hết rồi
thì các bạn mới bắt đầu làm chết nhá cho
nó ô và bây giờ sẽ là
con sự chết
con sự trên như vậy
trên
là
hôm trước anh mình thấy có tên Kiểu như
anh để viết tắt ngọn rất là dễ hiểu ngon
à
Cái quan đến lương
đi
thi à chất lương
nguyên dương
chất lương Là
Đớn bằng không đúng không nó sẽ Nguyên
Dương
tiếp theo
Hà Đông chưa Út lương không Lương thì
nếu mà các bạn cho người Việt thì rõ ra
là lương bằng kiểu y là được rồi Không
cần
đúng không Ok tiếp theo là
Anh tên này à
chế độ dài Tây nhà bạn ạ
khi gà llorente đúng không
lẽ hôm trước mình chỉ rồi nó là để lấy
độ dài của của chú ếch đúng không ạ
à à
Ừ cách mình sẽ copy đây cho các bạn diễn
Nhi này
à à
a
tiếp theo tuổi
có
phải lớn hơn 18 đúng không thì tôi sẽ ra
á con chưa chuyện nha tuổi
cũng được
nếu các bạn bè nha cũng được không sao
cả em đôi khi nhìn kìa này nó dễ bị mông
lung để mình đang định như thế này còn
tuổi này thì chắc à
hơn 18 đi chuyện nghe đi
Ừ nhưng mà thực ra mình thường Anh không
thích kiểu để cho cái số số hẳn ở trong
cái tên của một cái gì đó như này bởi vì
sau nếu mà các bạn sữa số ở đây thì các
bạn ở phía sửa lại tên đấy do mà chỗ này
thì chửi là chắc độ dài tên cũng giống
như tuổi đây Mình chỉ muốn ngắn gọn là
chị tuổi thôi
hơn là mình ghi hẳn là lớn hơn 18 ở
trong này thì về sau mình đổi tuổi là sự
đổi muốn đổi lên hay mưa tuổi mới được
cả thì mình lại thay đổi tên của cái này
nữa Thực ra thì cũng tốt
nhưng mà công nhận là nhìn kiểu như thế
nó tưởng minh hơn thật à
ở đây là có bạn nhiều bạn dùng là đét
đít cũng được hoặc là dùng kia mình
thường anh nhớ để cái vụ làm thì dùng về
đây thôi đúng không ghét Tết này chưa đi
ừ ừ
tình
yêu của ngài sinh đúng không
xong gọi lớn hơn 18A
à à
ừ ừ
ở tuổi Tý mặc định là nữ rồi
mặc định là nữ rồi ngày vào làm mặc định
hôm nay đúng không Để hôm nay rồi
à à
có nghề nghiệp phải nằm trong danh sách
này đúng không nằm trong danh sách thành
đạt đúng không Thì mình sẽ đã
copy cái này à
nghe được câu này cũng mình thấy gần như
các bạn đều có nhiều cách để làm rượu là
ở đây là
các bạn một là các bạn dùng theo kiểu là
Wave in trong cái danh sách được thưởng
như này các bạn copy luôn được cái này
của mình rất tiện
nằm trong cái danh sách này đương nhiên
phải thêm chữ N lần trước đúng không rồi
vì nó có dấu hay là các bạn o
đây baba phát thì mình thấy là thực ra
là cái này cũng được nhưng nghe các bạn
hãy thứ nhất là cốt các bạn nói chồng nó
dài hơn ra là cho nó không về tốc độ xử
lý cho nó không nhanh bằng in khuyên các
bạn vì sao mà chỉ có o như thế các bạn
nên dùng ý nó tiện hơn
cho tất cả cột không được để trống rồi
này mã nhân viên không được phép chung
thì nó là khóa chính mà Đúng không nhỉ
sẽ family kia thôi
Mình thực ra là các bạn để ý nên ti tự
động tăng này thì các bạn cũng sẽ không
trùng rồi
nhưng mà bảo nào cũng nên có khóa chính
Nên kiểu diễn sẽ sử dụng này
xin lỗi ở đây cạnh này nó sẽ bị lỗi cậu
nha à
em muốn rồi đúng không
Bên mình à
ở công ty còn 5 nhân viên đúng không Ok
5 nhân viên tất cả mình sẽ in search
đúng không Insert into nhân viên này
sau đó đi mình sẽ truyền đầy đủ thông
tin thôi
bạn lương chẳng ạ
Alo là
vẫn đó điều khúc lọng anh Long rồi anh
Tuấn đúng không
197 này
0101 này được tính một này ngày vào làm
thơ ngày giờ làm có bạn hôm trước làm
rất là Ôi nếu mà một là các bạn cho nhập
vào ngày và làm
như này mà các bạn muốn dùng đấy phô ấy
thì các bạn sẽ phải ghi hẳn để phô như
thế này để hiểu là mình muốn nhập vào để
for còn hay là các bạn sẽ phải không
nhập Thì nó sẽ hiểu lầm Chỉ cách vẽ hai
cách hiểu chưa
nghề nghiệp nghiệp thì mình hái thì ông
bà lương thì đã ra sự là cho 100 đi thế
cơ à cách để mình rất hiệu quả là các
bạn đến trang ai mà xem ngay những cái
câu ở dưới này có liên quan thì cái gì
đúng không
ở đáy Ví dụ ở đây Xóa những bạn nào
lương dưới 50 lại chẳng gặp thì kiểu gì
tí các bạn cũng nên có một ông nào đó
lương dưới 50 nó xóa đúng không chẳng
hạn thế nhớ cả là mới vào làm hai tháng
dưới hay đánh ấy chứ chán lắm Mình sẽ
phải có một ông như thế là đúng không Để
và hai shop là lấy tổng tiền mức lương
rồi trả theo từng nghề chuẩn thì ấm chị
phải có nhiều Nghe gì Gì đấy mới vào làm
hôm nay tất cả phải có người và lắm Hôm
nay Vân Vân Vân đúng không ạ
ở ngã bạn hiểu ý mình mà đúng không ạ
à à
Lê
Minh Tuấn
sinh năm 2000 tí nữa không Bây giờ làm
đặc sắc mà xin lỗi em
doanh nhân thành đạt này đúng không
lương để anh đấy à sản là thành đạt thì
hơn mình rồi Ngon tên anh ạ
ở gà
thí sinh tháng này nó có mạng sinh tháng
này là tháng 9 cho bạn ơi xin anh 09 là
nó ngon thì nha Một này
a
cho bạn đấy dưới 50k đi làm rộn 30.000
nhận cái là làm kế toán đi à
à à
chỉ
có mình mình nghĩa Ba bạn như này cháu
Ổn nghỉ thì anh Sơn nhé chắc không lỗi
gì đâu kêu thôi tiếp theo
những tháng ngày sinh nhật sếp có ông
đọc đề của tôi không kĩ nhá tháng ngày
sinh nhật sếp tức là ông phải chị
khi tăng lương cho những bạn nào sinh
tháng này thôi đúng không có ông thì làm
theo tuổi thì rất là nó không có cái này
sinh rồi Cái thứ nhất thứ hai là
ông Tăng lương mới tất cả mọi người sẽ
hơi say quá không đăng ký đây không chỉ
xinh cho thằng này thôi thì ở đây mình
sẽ làm đầu tiên à tăng lương thì thành
100 Tức là mình sẽ cập nhật Lương thành
100 đúng không là mình sẽ cập nhật cho
nhân viên này ngon xét
lương được ạ bằng 100 đi á đúng không
Đấy ông ấy làm chứ ngắn gọn như thế này
tất cả ai cũng đổ hết luôn à 100 thì đã
sai đúng không
đi à
thì các bạn phải đọc lại đó là xinh
tháng này đúng không là Wave ăn của ngày
sinh
bằng măn của ghét bếp tức là của tháng
này này đấy cậu ấy Thực ra nó gần nghiệm
của sao luôn Nếu chứ Nhưng mà thực ra là
mình mình làm cái này suốt rồi mà đúng
không
ừ ừ
khi chạy thử nhỉ
ở đó có một ông được đồ rồi đúng không
xem lại xem ông đấy ông nào nhé Chứ sao
form nhân viên này xong rồi que đúng cái
này xem ông được độ nhé
ở đó bạn tên anh rồi bạn ơi được đổi
đúng không
có
phải thì à
Ừ Ok bạn tên Anh bạn được vừa được cập
a tiếp theo tăng lương cho mỗi bạn thêm
100 Nếu là câu xa là đúng không Ok làm
thử có sang Á à
ạ bây giờ sự lá làm bài toán tăng lương
ra sự là
Ừ cái này của Ý ý câu ý của câu sau của
mình đang hiểu hiện đó là mình tách
riêng so với cái câu này làm có mới nhé
nghĩa là không thành một trăm nữa mà
tăng lương cho tất cả các bạn thêm 100
nghĩa lớn cũ Lương lưng
lương sẽ bằng lưng lương cũ cộng lên 100
hiểu chưa Ừ thì nó sẽ là có bạn dùng
cộng bằng
anh Minh chạy ở trên máy minh thì không
chạy được không biết được và chạy được
đấy À thế à Thế lại lừa rồi tại sao lúc
đầu mình chả được nghỉ
thử sẽ ra sao lại nhé á
em ở đường này được thế dùng cộng bằng
được nhưng mà các bạn nếu mà bạn mới học
lập trình các bạn sẽ không hiểu cổng
bằng là gì đúng không Mình cứ ghi rõ ra
cho các bạn dễ hiểu đã
cái này của vụ là cặp cái này Các bạn
nhìn nó hơi bị bay não tí Nếu nó gọn cho
hợp lập trình tự nhiên lương tự nhiên a
= a + 100 nghe cái này hơi sai với toán
học nhưng mà cái này nó sẽ hiểu cái bên
trái này nó sẽ ra cái giá trị mới mà
đúng không còn cả giá trị mới này sẽ
bằng cái gì cũ cộng với nhau thoải mái
được những thành ra nó thành ra kiểu như
này về chưa ạ
ờ ờ ờ thì cái này để các bạn dễ hình
dung hơn thì các bạn đã chắc phải làm
nhiều thôi đúng không ạ
à à
chứ còn cái gì nữa nhỉ
khi
cháu vừa được tăng lương đúng không
những câu sau dịch ra khó khăn các phạm
nhân sự luôn rồi Hơi tiếc
cho nghỉ việc bạn nào lương về 50 Thực
ra là mình lỡ tăng lương bạn kia rồi mà
thành ra bây giờ thì ra là xóa thì cần
lượng chẳng có bạn nào cả Thử nha phạm
nhân viên hoặc
Where lương nhỏ hơn 50 gì ngắm cái này
thực ra lại rất dễ so với cậu chết không
có bạn nào chẳng hạn ngờ bây giờ đến câu
sau này xóa cả bạn vừa mới thêm 100 nếu
lương cũ dưới 50 đúng không
tất cả sao nghĩa là xóa luôn cả những
cái bạn mà chính xác làm ý câu này của
mình thì e liên quan đến cái câu À cậu
màn câu này là Ừ cái bạn vừa mới thêm
đấy nghĩa mà những bạn sinh tháng này
vừa được tăng lương thì mình kiểm tra
xem là lương cũ nó dưới
U50 không Mình cũng đuổi những kẻ mang
tiếng là sinh nhật cùng của xếp nhưng mà
lương giờ 50 to lắm không không không
đáng thì ở lại cho cơ thể
thử nhé
anh nói thế đấy không không xúc phạm bạn
là lương ấy giờ 50 đâu ạ
Ừ
thì mình sẽ chỉ đơn giản như này không
Mình sẽ về nhà em em thêm cái này nữa
à à
Ừ nó đương nhiên là lương trong trường
hợp này mình sẽ là
50 + 100 đi Nếu là sự các bạn không biết
làm choáng mà không muốn làm toán hoặc
là làm toán một cộng một bằng hai cũng
phải dùng máy tính cả thì các bạn làm
như thế này máy tính có tự động tính hộ
cho bạn không như là chạy như này thì sẽ
không Bạn là bị xóa bởi vì vừa nãy còn
cho tăng lên phát nữa để bạn lên hẳn bao
nhiêu tiền chứ đúng không
các bạn anh nhớ lên hẳn lên Sư Tha nhà
200 mất rồi Ngon
ở nhà bạn hiểu ý mình mà Ngọc bây giờ ở
Nếu mà trong trường này có thể xóa bạn
tay cả các bạn tên anh đúng không ạ
cả hai con này sẽ giành độc lập nha
nghĩa là xóa thêm bạn chứ không không
ghét vào công này được vì con này cứ
chạy trước đã rồi mình đừng con này
anh không ý đôi khi nó sẽ bị sai bởi vì
có những bạn chưa thì được tăng lương
cũng bị bay màu mới rồi bởi vì mình thấy
có bạn vài bạn trả lời thì mỗi ngắn gọn
ngay thôi chị em chuyển bay luôn cả
những bạn mà không thể tăng lương nữa
không thể tăng lương Nhưng máy bay rồi
hơn cự thạch anh
ờ
ờ còn câu sao thì không nhỉ
anh ở đây đây
chị
đuổi cả nhân viên mới vào làm hai tháng
có mày hay sao nhưng mình mình thấy rất
nhiều bạn xài được đâu nhỉ Có chết mà
cũng lời được hòa cha không hiểu điều
này đây mình sẽ chỉ ra là
em
làm hai tháng đúng không Thì mình sẽ
phải ở có khái niệm là đấy tháng hiện
tại -
3 - tháng mới vào làm đúng không
Ừ
nhưng mà thực tế thì nếu mà bạn mà ghi
như thế này thì cái hơi bị sai này các
bạn dùng hàm kết bếp như thế này để lấy
tháng hiện tại đúng không - mâm của
ngài và làm này
không nói lớn hơn hai này Alo nhỏ hơn ai
mà mua như này nó bị sai tại sao là sai
bởi vì là ra xử này vào làm của các bạn
là là gia sửa tháng 9 rồi Đúng không
ngày và làm các bạn cũng là tháng 9
nhưng mà từ năm ngoái
ý thì cái này thử nó vẫn sẽ ra là bằng
không tất cả các bạn vẫn sẽ bị loại là
thế sai này ngon thì chuẩn nhất thì các
bạn lần này các bạn đã buộc phải đến đít
là - theo một khoảng thời gian nào đó
mình sẽ là - thèm ăn này sau đó restart
thì đây là sẽ ra ghét bếp này sau đó thì
đây là
ngày vào làm này nhằm chuẩn này
đúng là hay bị ngược lại nhé Mình không
chắc làm đâu để mình thử xem lại rồi à
thì mình phải lỡ cho cả ba bạn đã bị
Phong mới rồi mình thử Insert lại à mỗi
bạn
Ừ
tự nhiên mình bị Delete bay hết nhỉ Ừ cứ
thử chạy cho em có bài hết không nha Ok
cả ba bạn đều bay đúng không Thì tức cả
Chứng tỏ là cốc này chạy được Chắc thế
thay đổi lại này
cho bạn ấy vào làm chậm trễ và làm bằng
tương lai đường mà kiểu
áo kiểu dạng là
bạn đấy đăng ký trước kiểu tháng xong
nhận việc hay đại loại thế đúng không ta
tháng 10 nhãn 01
em và bạn này thì làm từ năm ngoái đi ai
không không mà tháng 9 9 0 1 có bạn này
cứ mặc định Bphone đi để xem Rốt cuộc
bay bạn nào đúng không
anh à Nếu mà thứ ra làm bằng
vì tương lai như này có khi hơi sai nữa
có khi vẫn bay quá
đổi đuôi việc trước để thư giãn nhé
U13 bạn bị thế sai mới dòm ngó
Ừ chim to là mình phải ngày và làm lên
trước chắc anh này mới đúng này em mình
sẽ lại con nữa này
Ừ ok này
anh có hai bạn bị
u2000 21 năm trước
đi gì đấy à
ở
Singapore nhà hàng đi làm luôn Ừ không
biết được Anh tận Còn như thế không ạ
Em lấy cây cây này để lại trường hợp này
lại sai đúng không bay bay sử bạn tương
lai đúng không Thế mà không ông nào để
cái quả mít này đúng không Mình sẽ phải
em Đúng rồi thì phải em là ngày vào làm
nhỏ hơn tiết đã
kiểu nó chết bay luôn cả ba luôn cả
những ông hiểu đăng ký tháng sau anh Năm
sau đó tự nhiên bay luôn
áo bóng đá
hình ảnh Ừ đấy nghĩa các bạn
Anh hiểu tại sao nó là hai sao chưa đúng
không
thì các bạn không đi ỉa chết
sợ ếch sao from nhânviên ạ
và có lẽ bây giờ cái bạn à
anh vẫn bay cái bạn cả đời đấy Đúng rồi
ngày vào làm của bạn là như thế này
trúng cái ổn không ạ
à à
Ừ tự nhiên đến lúc chữa mấy cô sao tôi
thấy tôi để ý thấy ạ hai mươi mấy ông
Aoi nhé như cậu mấy ông nữa thấy Khôi
chết câu sao rồi phải bỏ qua thôi
Ý
tao là nói chung là các bạn xem lại thì
cũng nhớ chịu khó làm bài tập nha ở đây
rồi không có điểm danh cũng không cục
Kiểm tra rất lòng gì cả Nên là các bạn
đã tự giác rồi mà đúng không tự giác đây
là đúng cái nghề mà mà mà
nó còn miễn phí nữa để các bạn tự giác
này chủ yếu thôi
anh lớn hết cả rồi đúng không ạ à à
300 nhẹ không cần phải kiểm tra điều
kiện ngày vào làm vậy
phải cậu bé hơn ngày hiện tại hay lớn
ngày hiện tại ở đây bởi vì à Như mì nói
18 thể đăng ký trước mà đúng không ạ
à à
ý nghĩa tổng tiền mỗi tháng trước phải
trả cho nhân viên này thì sẽ trăm lương
đúng không
là xong hôm nhân viên này à
à à
ở đó như này xong theo từng nghề có sao
của tôi mà Mấy ông kiểu làm cũng Bách
hết rồi Còn mấy ông làm cái kiểu như này
đó là mấy ông ngồi gõ lại đúng que theo
từng nghề luôn ạ ạ dậy chưa
Mình sẽ lại chơi trò sẽ exom đúng không
Thế này sau đó gì à
quay nghề nghiệp
bằng này tiếng
đúng ngay
Ừ thì À thì ra đây nhanh Các bạn thấy
cái này nó Nguyễn ra đúng không sôi các
bạn Ware heo cùng mỗi 3 nghề các bạn
quay ba phát từ cá thế không tốt người
vì sao Bởi vì à từ mình mà lấy cái trong
một công ty có tận đã phải 30 40 phòng
ban ngành nghề có điều thứ mặn que thì
chết à Ngủ Ngon thì mình sẽ phải làm như
nào
ừ ừ
Ừ thì mình sẽ hôm nay mình cái thứ mà
hôm nay mình sẽ học đấy đúng không nó sẽ
liên quan đến group bang Đúng chưa
mình sẽ khái niện bạn Goodbye theo nghề
nghiệp các bạn sẽ thấy à Lúc đầu có bạn
chạy cái này đã đúng không chạy cái này
thì nó sẽ không nhóm theo cái nghề gì cả
lấy tắt có mưa nó xin nhóm cho người sẽ
ra như thế này đương nhiên là các bạn
nhìn đây này các bạn sẽ hơi khó hiểu
không biết bốn trăm cùng ngày nào cũng
giống như là 100 ngày của người nào đúng
không các bạn sẽ mình sẽ lách nó như thế
này thì bảo sẽ hiển thị ra được thôi
đúng không làm nghề rồi kèm theo đơn như
là các bạn để Adidas ở đây rồi à tổng
lương trở lại gì đấy đúng không
cái các bạn chạy này thì nó sẽ ra là
nghề kết hợp với
những tấm gương ở ngay bên cạnh Đúng
chưa Thì cái này nó rất tiện thì
theo kiểu đã các bạn nhóm theo cái gì đó
Cái này không phải nhóm theo Mỗi nghề
các bạn hoàn toàn thực tế là đơn nhiên
là có thể nhóm heo rất nhiều thứ thì
mình sẽ học chuyên sâu hơn ví dụ là nhóm
theo tên là những bạn tới Long thì mức
lương tâm lương là gì hay ở mức lương
Chung bừng trung bình của tất cả các bạn
đấy Long này đã lại thế nếu bao nhiêu
tên thật chứ Probi còn theo cả nhiều cột
nữa Cái này cho chuyên sâu hơn tí mình
có thể mình sẽ đặt cọc
nhà bè cứ làm đơn giản chưa hết cả các
cài đã đúng không ạ
xe
tải thì các bạn sẽ xảy ra thì câu này
thế thôi đúng không Câu này Hôm nay thì
bản chất là mình có hoa
a cho các bạn cảm thấy
làm được thêm không nữa rồi cao nó cũng
chẳng thay đổi gì mấy đúng không nó sẽ
là theo từng nghề gì sẽ mình chị đổi đây
đúng không trung bình lương rồi được
ngon thấy da nó cũng không khác gì mấy
chị thay đổi hàng mà
anh nghe này đúng không ạ
xe đẩy ra các bạn mới vào làm hôm nay
đây có ông thì bảo là câu này dễ nhưng
mà em lại không ra kết quả hơn nó vỡ
vùng cửa rồi em chạy được rồi nhưng
không ra kế hoạch
tại sao Vì nếu mà còn snack sao cong
nhân viên như thế này mà có bạn chị nó
già Noel này vào làm
cũng bằng đúng cái ghế hết ạ Các bạn
nghĩ rằng ạ Đúng rồi Má rõ ràng em ở
trên em về phô nó ghét bếp thì dưới mà
ghét hết theo chuẩn rồi còn đi xa đâu
đúng không chạy này nó không đưa ra kết
quả gì cả Tại sao Vì ghét bếp này mà các
bạn select nó ra thì ghét ghét này nó sẽ
bao gồm cả ngày tháng năm rồi phút giây
thì ra năm tháng ngày giờ phút giây
không thì à
Ừ thì các bạn thấy là
cái ngày và làm các bạn các bạn lưu lại
là đếch thôi đúng không biết thôi chứ
còn 5 tháng này thôi thì làm sao nó thể
bằng được cả cái cụm này đằng sau đúng
không sẽ bằng được thì có hai cách một
hôm vừa rồi mình xem có bạn làm cũng khá
phức tạp không Tí đó là bạn sẽ dùng đế
típ đúng không để mặt trừ cái phải bệnh
đây vậy trừ cái ngày ạ
này vào làm này
với ghét biết có một ý hay xong rồi đấy
ạ bằng không thì ạ để lấy ngày hôm nay
cho hợp lý mà
Ừ đúng nhỉ
từ ngày vào làm
anh đợi mình sẽ Mã ừ ừ
ở nhà bà Oanh trước hay đến sau nhỉ
Ừ tao đâu nhỏ con không Ngon không Ngon
không đúng rồi nhỏ hơn không một việc
bởi vì à bằng không thì phải khớp Khớp
hoàn toàn nhắn không thôi ok ra rồi đúng
không à Nhưng mà cách này Thực ra nó
phức tạp hơn các bạn bài toàn đơn giản
lắm các bạn mà vừa rồi vẫn là so sánh
những ngày và làm đúng không
Và Ghét Ghét cái đúng rồi Nhờ như mình
đã nói gì thì mình chỉ cần lấy 5 tháng
này ở từ cái ghét ghét thôi các bạn sẽ
trao Google nó là ghét cont đây là lại
anh khuya này tại như thế này thì nó sẽ
ra ngay cái quả đó là ghét coolbit
wartime này đái vào nó sẽ có khái niệm
là như thế này nó sẽ là Cát nó sẽ biến
đổi cái một cái chúa gì đó thành cái gì
đó nhìn anh là như này là xong bạn chạy
thử
cho nên nó không ra đậu xanh
thì tại sao không gian này xem thử đã
nhé
ờ đúng à ngày vào làm của ông kia ngày
bao nhiêu nhỉ
chỉ sau 20 vào nhau được
em đọc không đi à
các bạn Đấy lại mình xem lại nhé
ở ngay và làm của ông kia là
à À ngon
I don't know mìn sót lại hình như làm ào
mình delete mình đi lễ rồi Xin lỗi Xin
lỗi lửa lửa
cho da mình khử cho bạn đấy ạ
Khi bữa nay chạy được này chạy được nó
ra đúng không
Vì sao
ừ ừ
Ừ nhưng mà cái này các bạn kể cả xấu dù
vừa rồi mình đi sớm đúng không Rồi mình
à cho thử bằng lại cái này nhé nó cũng
không ra đâu Cái này mình thoảng đi luôn
cái này kiến thức mà ngon kiến thức thì
phải chắc chứ
anh lại không ra là đúng không Đó được
chưa cũng như là cái vừa rồi nít này
nếu thấy có thể đến đít bằng không chắc
là nó được đấy thử thử ngày vào làm đi
ngoài
với ghét ghét này
bằng không đi cha có khi nó ra đấy
ở đó ra rồi đúng không thấy mình nhớ
bằng không là hợp lý mà
anh lại có hai cách này đúng không ạ
ở đâu phim mới có một tiếng mà ông đã
bảo 90 phút rồi à
có ai nghĩa các bạn dùng một trong hai
cái này nhưng mình thấy Là cách này nó
trông có vẻ từng minh hơn đúng không còn
cái này thì đúng là kiểu các bạn biết về
cái Hà mày giờ thì các bạn dùng cậu
không sai
ờ ờ Còn gì nữa không nhỉ lấy ba bạn em
cái cũng nhất trí không phải bye hôm nay
mình học này thì ra nó rất là ngắn không
Cái này chỉ đơn giản là mình sẽ là
select sao form nhân viên
order vai
ta cũng nhất ở đây tức là chỉ là ngày
vào làm Ngọc là ai si tượng này và làm à
từ
tăng dần đúng không
anh Bởi vì ngày vào làm càng cũ tất cả
càng bé mà không lại nó tăng dần nếu mà
lấy như này thì nó sắp xếp treo này vào
làm rồi nó và mình muốn lấy ba thì top 3
thôi đúng không cấp 3 thôi Xong
Ừ có anh sẽ lấy ba chưa Đây là khái niệm
về
remix được chưa khái niệm mà khái niệm
Lipit Chưa remix tất cả món giới hạn số
kết quả trả về
tiếp theo mình muốn đẩy
ở câu 2 sao này
thì mình sẽ để buổi sau mình chữa nhé
Thơ rất nhiều Bạn làm đến con này tắt
bạn ấy rất mong buổi hôm nay chữa nhiều
ạ tại khác đến buổi sau buổi sau mình
dậy về việc tạo nhiều bạn nữa đúng không
Mà hôm nay mình sẽ dạy cái đi tiếp giả
sử là các bạn muốn bỏ qua ba bạn mày đấy
ba bạn tiếp theo chẳng hạn vô mình mình
nghĩ sót thì người cũng khá nhiều đấy
Bình thử xem thử nhé
ở đây là sự là mình có sáu bạn đúng sáu
bạn luôn à Ừ thì khi mình sẽ lách như
thế này thì rõ ra Các bạn thấy mười một
8 14 như là bây giờ mình muốn bỏ qua ba
bạn để lấy ba bạn tiếp theo đúng không
Thì mình làm như nào thì nó sẽ Khái niệm
và offset họp xét thì da mình không ngờ
offset ở trong Express server là gì đâu
nên mình cứ gửi tra xem nó có dùng được
không nhá Ừ
a fake vào để mình thử xem
khi học sat fake nén cũng hơi khó hiểu
đại offset người đâu Chắc thể học sat bà
bầu em ạ Đã bỏ qua bao lâu gì
à à
Ừ chắc là được sẽ Hữu này
thì tốt nhất không lấy được phép mặc
I thought shed thì không kết hợp việc
tốt mà kết hợp với fake Ok thử nhé á
à à
ừ ừ
khoa học CF
3z Sam à
à À đấy
hình ảnh
Ừ chắc phải nếu mà các bạn kết hợp Limit
offset ở trong SQL Server thì các bạn
hãy chơi theo cách như lai như thế thì
mai queo viết này nó sẽ tiện hơn
axwell viết nó sẽ nhàn hơn rất nhiều các
bạn sẽ thử xem sao xanh với máy Nokia
nhé bởi bên máy của em hãy cho mình sẽ
giận thì bên Mai Phương đến như vì sao
mình sẽ nhắc lại khi mà dậy lại về máy
của em nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ nói qua các
bạn lại bạn thấy nó sẽ dễ dàng hơn
Limit 3G offset ba như này xong này
nó sẽ dễ hiểu hơn hiểu lấy lấy chỉ có 3
bạn ghi và được nha Bỏ qua bạn kia Thậm
chí các bạn hãy viết tắt hiệu kiểu như
này
Ừ thì nó sẽ hiểu là lấy 3 và bỏ qua ba
được trong nó sẽ rất là từng Minh sau ấy
kéo lúc cái dùng tốt lúc bị dùng fake
họp xét các thứ bên Express server ngày
nay
Ừ ừ đấy do mà thực là nhiều nơi thích
dậy máy cao hơn là
ashwell bụi server Nếu mà hãy qua server
Chính vì nó cũng hơi rườm rà nhà ngon Nó
lại hỗ trợ nhiều hơn sau làm em quen mấy
queo nó nhỏ gọn hơn
đãi về khái niệm về à Cái liên quan đến
hôm nay mình bảo nó thống kê các thứ thử
anh
không cần fake Ừ trong trường hợp này
bởi vì À bởi vì rõ ràng là ô xét 3 thìa
như chỉ còn 3 thôi đúng không Thì không
cần fake Nhưng mà nếu bây giờ sử mà các
bạn muốn lấy ba thằng à Một lấy 221 Hằng
ngay sau ba tháng thì thôi nha các bạn
phải thêm phách mà đúng không
ông chủ nhật chạy thử nhé
Ừ đúng rồi bây giờ mình muốn chị lấy một
thằng sau 3 hàng thì mình phải thêm
phách chứ đúng không để lấy giới hạn chỉ
có một thằng sau đó thôi à
Ô
kìa Cái hôm nay thử ca mình không chỉ
muốn dạy như thế này mà mình muốn dạy
các bạn chuyên sâu về cái Du pied một tí
về cứ xem lại nhé xem lại đây này
em vừa rồi Vừa nãy mình có Goodbye theo
có nghề nghiệp dư ngon các bạn hoàn toàn
này Goodbye Hair rất nhiều cái nữa Thật
sự là bây giờ mình có thể rút bay theo
giới tính thậm chí là cả kết hợp cả hai
cột về nhau cũng được hoặc 3 theo tên
cũng được ra sự ở đây mình nhưng mà
trong trường hợp nếu các bạn Goodbye là
sự của bạn nhập tên là sẽ nào các bạn sẽ
không đủ sẽ lấy sao mình nữa và sẽ báo
lỗi bởi vì tất cả những cụt không nằm
trong new Bike hướng ở đây nó có Ai Cập
là các bạn sẽ không Không nhìn thì ở đây
được lỗi được chưa Nhưng các bạn bắt
buộc phải phải ghi thì nhớ là tên cột ở
đây đã cái đấy cứ thử thứ nhất là sẽ lấy
được đây thứ hai là
các bạn sẽ dùng những cái Hà mình còn bị
xăm này cao là anh trung bình lấy trung
bình
identified cái gì đấy
mày cái hàm đấy gọi là hàm ở đây nó khái
niệm hàm à
ogress Gì đấy Này bể thì thì mới dùng
được ở trong Goodbye đây ví dụ là mình
sẽ xăm lưng nhỉ đúng không
à à
xe tải thì liệt kê tổng lương của tất cả
những bạn có cái tên này đúng không sẽ
lắp trùng mà hộ cho mình lọc Chung nhé
đầu tiên lập chung đúng không có ai kết
hợp việc là nó sẽ liên quan đến những
cái hàm thống kê thì ra thấy hàm thống
kê tiền mà tính toán hội chứng minh
em ở nhà mình có thể giúp bay theo cảnh
nhiều cái nữa Thật sự là mình ở đây mình
người bể có một bạn tên Long nhưng mà
bạn đấy để giới tính là nữ đi chẳng hạn
thế
Hà
Tĩnh không đi lại lương hẳn lên 500 đi
5.000 thôi hơi quá đáng được mình hài
lòng với bạn Tiểu Long Nữ
em ở nhà thì có bạn sẽ thấy đầu tiên đây
thì nếu mà chịu rút bay theo tên Long
Thôi thì tiền nó sẽ lên hẳn 5.000 hay
đúng không Nhưng mà nếu ra sự là thêm cả
roba theo cả
tên là kèm với cả giới tính như thế này
Ừ thì có bạn sẽ thấy là hai cái này đang
bị tách ra rồi đúng không với bạn tên
Long giới tính nó không thì lương mà dậy
như này nhưng bạn tên Long rồi tính làm
một thì lương nó sẽ chỉ này thôi
có thêm thắc mắc thứ hai mà hồi đấy mình
cũng rất là đau đầu đó là
Goodbye được nhiều cột như Ngài đã do
phức tạp rồi Thậm chí là các bạn sẽ thắc
mắc à mình để cái cột này trước một này
có được không Thực ra bài toán nó được
Nhưng mà phải toàn nó lai kìa mình sẽ ưu
tiên
ngọt nhà nghỉ
anh như tiên nhóm thằng nào trước thôi
nhóm nào trước đấy mẹ thử nó không hẳn
là thay đổi và mặt logic đâu theo mình
là như thế bởi vì đó
Ừ tao kiểu gì Mỹ phải Lộc Trung
thì các bạn thấy được à mình để nó hạnh
trước và sao nó không đem lại ý nghĩa gì
đấy cả thực sự như thế
hoặc các bạn thấy nó chỉ ở nhóm đưa tin
nhóm thằng nào trước thì mặc tên đầy nó
lên đầu hai giới tính cái đầu vân vân
Nhưng mà còn kết quả thì nó vẫn sẽ là
như thế chưa Nên là các bạn không quan
tâm việc cái thứ tự cái này lắm mà các
bạn quan tâm việc là phải bay sao cho
đúng cho tí thôi
mình sẽ ở đây à khóa học này khoa học cơ
bản em mình sẽ toàn nói toàn bộ những
cái đó chỉ cần Cơ bản một tí các bạn
hoàn toàn được tìm hiểu thêm cũng giống
như là có bạn bảo vệ Minh là thực ra là
đến buổi hôm nay là bắt đầu dậy khứ
nhanh rồi vì thường em họ trên lớp em
học Insert update Delete có khi mất sự
ba bốn buổi nhưng mà Đây cũng là anh
trực tiếp rồi của việc online đó các bạn
sẽ phải tự học ở nhà nhiều cũng làm bài
tập thì ra làm một bài của mình từ A vẫn
còn ít đấy bởi vì à học cốt này để mà
các bạn nhớ thì các bạn bắt buộc ngoài
phải hiểu thì phải thực hành rất nhiều
những một bài thơ Ra chưa đủ lâu các bạn
sẽ phải
anh làm đi em lại khá nhiều bài tương tự
tự nghĩ là để cho mình để làm thì mình
mới nhớ được
các bạn và để nói chung là để bạn hiểu
đúng không thể tự mòi nhiều mình không
thể
buổi hôm nay lại dậy lại bổ Hôm trước
chỉ thay đổi mỗi bài tập được mình bắt
buộc phải dậy tăng tiền đúng không dạy
thêm kiến thức mới
nhưng mà các bạn vẫn phải tự chủ động ở
nhà học thôi đúng không Thế lúc đầu mình
định là thì hai buổi thôi để những thời
gian có lại các bạn sẽ chỉ cắm đầu vào
học
tự ôn tập nhưng mà thực ra thì không ai
không ai ép được các bạn nên có khi ở
nhà các bạn cũng ôn tập lí Đông làm được
bài tập mình chắc là căng mắn rồi
nhưng mà cái này cũng nói thế để cho bạn
biết được lại ra đền cái và lút bye này
khi mình đi dạy ở trên đấy nó cũng phải
lên đền á
ở buổi à 18 19 chứ không phải là đến
buổi đầu năm đã dậy cái mới gai hàm như
này luôn rồi Đâu
là đến buổi sau nữa buổi sau mình sẽ cố
dạy tách kể cái buổi liên quan đến khoa
ngoại ít nhất phải hay buồn
ý kiến thức cơ bản và kiến thức sâu hơn
tí nhưng mà các bạn cũng phải làm bài
tập nhiều hơn và nghĩ trên bài này là
kiêu kiêu thế
anh nói chung nhà tạm cái đức của Mai
Thế em mình thử trả lời em và bình luận
các bạn nhé
Ý anh là giảng viên trường BKA a b cái
từ cơ
Đó là hình như là đúng đúng cũng có viết
tắt Đúng chưa mà nhiều Đấy chính xác tên
trường của mình biết cái cái cái cái
nhưng mà đúng với k viết thì ra cũng
đúng rồi việc nó là Bách Khoa academy mà
nó học viện thế này ra là nó vẫn đúng
à à
ở armenia không biết được các trường
khác dạy nhà vốn dĩ hâm Mình đã học của
các chữ cái đầu đúng không Nhưng mà mình
mình theo theo cái kính nhiễm dùng thử
kinh nghiệm cũng ngoài phép từ công nhận
là mình đi dạy phải hơn hai năm rưỡi rồi
mà mình dậy đi dậy lại cái video này nó
cũng khá nghiền nhuyễn rồi
nên à Mình nghĩ thế này là tốc độ cũng
nhanh nhưng mà mình nghĩ à các bạn làm
xong rồi những bài thi ấy Chắc là làm 23
bài đấy các bạn sẽ hiểu Nhưng mà hiểu là
một chuyện
thì các bạn còn phải nhớ nữa đúng không
thì các bạn sẽ phải trau dồi thêm
ờ ờ anh mình quên mất đã bây giờ mình
thì nói với hack nghỉ tại từ nhiều lo
của mình sẽ nhắc về hack nhé
ừ ừ
à à những kiến thức là những cái những
cái câu hỏi các bạn đang hỏi được ra lại
các bạn trai để một tí bây giờ cũng à
thời khác để có ông chủ động thể hiện
mình là giờ này đi rồi ông tò mò cái gì
ông lên trang cá nhân của tôi hoa quả
thực ra từ chưng cho cá nhân tôi mà
không mò được thì ông người mà qua blog
vân vân để ra thử thông tin nữa Thôi nếu
em thực sự muốn tò mò đúng không
Bởi vì mình cũng từng làm thế với mấy
bạn gái mình thích chẳng ạ Nhưng mình
phải tìm hiểu sâu mà nó học
à à
cho con hỏi Bây giờ thì thực ra mình trả
lời rồi sao mình trả lời đi Trả lời lại
nó cũng hơi bị ngàn đấy à
hai tay time Attack là gì đúng không cái
à
Nếu như mình lúc đầu mình có nói thăm
Attack
tức à hình thức đo để bật tính
đo để mã tấn công đo thời gian để tấn
công cái gì đó Nó kiểu dặn và
kiểu này đương nhiên là bây giờ khó mà
áp dụng được ít nhất là cho mình cái
trang lớn còn rất nhiều trai hiện tại nó
vẫn còn dính thì mình sẽ thử nói chung
là mình sẽ không nói lại cái bài đăng
này các bạn nên tìm bài đăng này đọc
nhưng mà bạn đang này viết nó cũng tương
đối dễ hiểu nhưng mà có kết hợp cả bên
ngôn ngữ lập trình nghe này có nhiều bạn
nhìn thấy sẽ hơi bị choáng còn bên mình
sẽ nói hiểu ý hiểu của mình khi mà đọc
xong bài này
cao như thế này
cái này nó hai cục công nhận hai cục đây
để mình thử nó phải cho bạn nha ở đầu
tiên là sử các bạn muốn hack dùng cái
Trang nó đúng không Thì
em giả sử của mình thôi có lấy Facebook
cũng có nghe Giả sử mình cứ nói vụ ra
chúng mình muốn hack Facebook chặn ạ
đúng không Mày thêm thì nào Chim trên
youtube lên Facebook gọi sẽ không đánh
bản quyền mình câu này không đánh gậy
mình đây A khi
để đăng nhập Facebook thì các bạn phải
điền cái gì Email và mật khẩu hoặc email
mật khẩu word đã sử email của mình là
abc@gmail.com và mật khẩu của mình ra sự
với nhé một hai ba bạn ạ ngon đấy
Ừ thì mình giờ sửa Mình có đăng ký một
cái tài khoản
ở đây mình có đăng ký một tài khoản là
như thế này tôi chưa ạ
Ừ
ok chưa Sau đó thì mình đăng nhập đăng
nhập vào đấy nhưng mình đăng ký như này
vào đăng nhập vào thì đương nhiên được
luôn đúng không một thành công không
thành công
cái toán đây chẳng gì xảy ra là mình
không thể hack nick chính mình nghe mùi
Cường vậy mà Thế mình lúc mình đăng ký
làm gì ngon mình thành công nhưng mình
sẽ đo được là thời gian đăng nhập
thành công là bao nhiêu đây
là sử sử mày toàn đăng nhập thành công ở
đây mình mất 2 giây ạ
Tại sao thật sự là mình mất 1 giây để mà
kiểm tra Email máy chủ làm việc vẫn một
giây Kiểm tra Email mẫu dây kiểm tra mật
khẩu em ạ đúng không
Nhưng các bạn phải hiểu bên Bất Trị
nghiện thì
ở thời gian đăng nhập thành công nó luôn
nhanh hơn rồi ra đang cực đăng nhập thất
bại các bạn bây giờ từ lên rất nhiều
trang web mà các bạn đăng nhập và thầy
nó rát rát Một lúc lâu ấy hồi trước phải
bụng bị gì nhé bảo là kiểu các bạn biết
thừa là mình đang đang nhập sai rồi kêu
chị Năm thông báo về màu trắng lỗi
các bạn thử mà xem rất nhiều Trang đi bị
đến bây giờ vẫn thế
thì à Tại sao tự nhiên mà nói về đăng
nhiều thất bại rồi Bây giờ ông mày sẽ
thấy một giây thử email và một dây thử
mật khẩu đúng không Ông ấy thử đăng nhập
lại
với tài khoản là Ace vẫn là Email là ABC
ngay nhưng mật khẩu cho thằng say mặt
nhiều Vina xây nhà trường ạ đúng không
Thì ông ấy thấy kết quả trả về
lên tới ba giây ạ Từ đó ta có cái ngôn
luận là gì
ở dạng thôi đòi lại
D3 dây là thất bại đúng không Nhưng
ở
đây là với ạ
Em email đúng Ông ấy chỉ nhập gửi mail
chất chọn size size luôn cả email cả mật
khẩu nghe trở lại email chữ toàn không
mở tồn tại với một cái mật khẩu sẽ sáng
mà nó chẳng tồn tại của Email này kết
quả Sẽ Về Nói lên bốn giây
thì từ đó phát có nghĩa là ông ấy sẽ
chạy một cái con bóp một con tự động ông
ấy lập trình hoa càng phải trên mạng về
Ừ để chặn Farm liên tục của các trang
web đấy
ở
spam email ngẫu nhiên
Em email sinh nhắn ngẫu nhiên đấy hiểu
thế bà toàn bộ kết quả trả về là ba giây
chiều nó sẽ hiểu là
số trang web này có email đấy Tân An
thôi nghe hợp lý không thì suy ra lấy
được
toàn bộ email của trang web đấy
ok chưa đó là xăm mình là tách và các
bạn vừa nghe xong cũng
sức khỏe khó hiểu hay giới thiệu đến
đoạn này ạ
số điện thoại này bắt bắt kịp không ạ
khi mình ăn để độ Trễ của bình luận nó
lên tận 30 giây một phút đấy nhưng chắc
ạ Phải đợi một lúc mình biết về câu trả
lời các bạn ạ
ừ ừ
à à à
à à
anh
nghe đấy Loại này thì các bạn hiểu rồi
đúng không cái thì
nhưng mà có bạn thì bảo là hack
khi hack như này thì
Anh cũng anh cũng có để làm gì đâu đúng
không biết mũi email đúng không Nhưng mà
không cái này nó liên quan đến bài Toán
thứ hai đó Khi mà các bạn biết được toàn
bộ email của mình cái trang web rồi đúng
không Thì bây giờ mình cần xuống dò
đường mật khẩu chưa
do ra được mật khẩu như nào thì thằng
Facebook nó lại có cơ chế như này à
không không Ngoài Facebook mà lập trình
máy tính chiều có cơ chế như thế này Hôm
trước mình nói mày toàn nó sáng chuỗi
đúng không
như sau thành chuỗi thì nó sẽ như này ra
xử ở đây mình có
ở chỗ làm à như này đúng không
ở đây Mật khẩu của mình đúng không Chúng
mình nhập đã bên này giá Aba như thế này
hoặc là ba này theo các bạn
và đương nhiên tất cả đều là sai đúng
không nên treo các ạ trường hợp nào là
trường hợp trả về thông báo sai nhanh
nhất và trường hợp nào trường hợp cho về
thông báo sai lâu nhất
thứ
hai nó đi bằng nhau
phụ đề để mật khẩu cho
lần thử đầu tiên này lần thứ hai này lần
thứ 3 trường hợp nào là trường hợp thông
báo sai trở về nhanh nhất mà trường hợp
nào thông báo Xanh trở về lâu nhất
Ừ để tạm boot thì cắn học phí học lập
trình này học giáo trình chính tạo tune
tại port tự động được mặt
à à
à À chắc bạn mới vào bởi vì mình phải để
đền đây một tí rồi vì ạ
thời gian đầu vừa nãy ít tự nhiên video
Nó kiểu nó bị à mà bị kiểu mát thế kiểu
các bạn xem độ phân tải bị thấp thì là
phải để độ trễ lớn hơn để các bạn nhìn
được màn hình mà không biết lắp
Ừ đúng rồi còn có vài bạn trả lời
Ừ
đúng rồi kìa nó là ba nhanh nhất và một
lâu nhất tại sao Vì bài toán là máy tính
nó kiểm tra nó sẽ kiểm tra từ trái sang
phải và kiểm tra dụa đúng này nó mất 0,5
giây đúng không thì kiểm tra từ này tiếp
thế nào ah đầy đủ ngủ tiếp Lại mất 0,5
giây nữa sau đó thì A về B xa rồi đúng
không nó mất giờ xử một giây ạ thì tổng
cộng thằng này sẽ mất là 2,5 giây và sự
thế thôi nhá tương tự Thường ngày là A
đúng này 0,5 này a b sai này 1,5 lại
đúng không Con trường hợp này nó sẽ trả
về luôn là một giây đúng không
khi ở đây từ đây thì các bạn sẽ
thì
các bạn sẽ thấy là mật khẩu nào càng gần
đúng khi thời gian phản hồi về càng lâu
Cô Đơn giản thế thôi đúng không Thì mình
lại chạy con boss nó sẽ tự động sinh ra
mật khẩu đúng không Thế mày ngồi dò mật
khẩu b vì vừa nãy mình lấy được email
rồi mà không mình sẽ dò mật khẩu của
Tuấn email một sau đó thì mình mình sẽ
thử một cái chuỗi ngẫu nhiên và chỗ làm
à càng thời gian chào người càng lâu thì
chứng tỏ là mật khẩu càng gần đúng rồi
đấy thuế ra được mật khẩu thôi à
Ừ cái đương nhiên là bài toán bây giờ
thực là đây do mật khẩu mà các bạn phải
nên dài hơn 8 ký tự thì tốc độ tốc độ để
mạnh thread ra được cá mực để mà đoán
được mật khẩu qua con boss nó tốn nhiều
thời gian
ở chương 11 khẩu nhắn như thế này kết
hợp với không ký tự đặc biệt thì cha nó
rất là nhanh à
Cho
tôi mua bút fortec chỉ ra hình thức tấn
công kiểu ngồi dò mật khẩu đây ạ
Ẩm Thực ra thực tế còn nhiều bạn thì sẽ
phản bác lại ý kiến này ngay đó nơi kiểu
anh không để ý với tốc độ mạng à hay là
cá mập cắn Internet à Vân Vân Vân ở đây
có bạn ở dưới cũng nói bạn này cũng nói
đó là kiểu này
ừ ừ
3 Cách Tấn Công này hơi bất khả thi vì
nó liên quan đến thuốc này sức động sức
mạnh của máy tính này cá mập này cách
mạng 4.0 vẫn luôn Vân này đấy Thì thực
tế là ở đây có vai toán này nó nó mức
dao động đó chị ở chênh lệch một khóa
một cái lượng nhất định thôi thì ạ Thì
mình vẫn có thể đo lường được cái đấy
cho
nên là thực tế là chúng ta cũng phải cân
nhắc mình bài toán này à
3000 mã hóa ở đây không liên quan gì bạn
ơi Không không không liên quan đến mã
hóa gì đấy cả mã hóa để cho khi mình
nhập và lên Như mình phải vẫn phải nhập
mật khẩu thôi chứ mình làm sao mình nhập
khẩu mã hóa được đúng không mã hóa đây
chỉ để như ông nào mà dò được tạo bởi
các bạn biết được về các bạn mà không
không dịch được cái đoạn Mã hóa đấy
ngược lại thôi Chứ còn lúc mà nhận mật
khẩu thương nhân chỉ nhập thôi mà nhưng
không liên quan đến mã hóa đây hết ý
Ừ Kệ đi hỏi cho nhanh tôn chạy bằng cơm
Bạn vừa nãy nói thì nó liên quan đến một
kỹ thuật khác nó social
Engineering nữa
chỉ nghệ xã hội
bộ phim rất hay về cái này nó chính là
Obama War về hacker dân nổi rất dễ hiểu
và rất là hay về ạ Hai cơ mình nha mình
nha biết là hay
ừ ừ
anh đấy đấy đấy là một trong lý do bây
giờ để tránh boss chỉ đứng ở phải có
thêm cắt tra rồi các thứ gì nữa đúng
không ạ
à à
anh không Nó ban mật khẩu trước khi gửi
cũng chả liên quan gì đây là nó không
liên quan mã hóa mình nói thôi và thời
ra có cái trang web sợ How cho ý cho
password này bạn thể tra thử trên này
thử xem cái mật khẩu các bạn Nga dùng
mật khẩu hiện tại của mình ra như thế
này thì máy mua cái máy bình thường ấy
một cái máy bình thường cũng thế
thì nó sẽ như thế này nó sẽ hiểu
Nó sẽ phải chạy bao nhiêu bài toán này
và mất bao nhiêu lâu để ngồi ra được một
cái mật khẩu như thế này
dù mật khẩu Facebook của mình hiện tại
như này ạ
Ừ
đấy thì các bạn sẽ tự nhập mật khẩu của
mình lên đây xem đúng không
xe Hoa Mai ở Liga Mình thỉnh thoảng mình
hơi ngáo Tí Nếu không rõ các bạn tra hu
hu hu I'm hacker thì ra là nó vẫn đang
là Cái phim đấy thôi Hay mà đúng không ạ
Ừ ừ
hu hu i am thì những có sai chính tả
tiếng Anh xin lỗi à
bộ
mã hóa rồi cho So sánh 2 chuỗi mã hóa
cái này Thực ra là lại kiến thức nó khá
phức tạp thì da mình có lọc đấy và nó
liên quan đến cũng có mình còn lưu lại
rồi mình nghĩ là sẽ Mình cũng định nói
các bạn nhưng mà chắc là đến vì sau cơ
Cái liên quan đến 300 và lưu bát cốc
đúng cách bạn hãy đọc qua bài này đã
em xin các bạn ạ Có liên quan đến
Rainbow table là kiểu hacker nó nó lấy
được cái data bậy các bạn cái database
mà các bạn để lưu thông tin tài khoản
người dùng không lưu lại còn mật khẩu
người dùng đúng không mà các bạn mã hóa
rồi thì các bạn phải biết cách mã hóa
sao cho để cho hacker nó không tra ngược
lại được đã đi
khi nhập mật khẩu lên trang này có nguy
cơ bị đánh cắp không thầy
Ừ mình không sát bởi vì thừa xây nhiều
người dùng đấy Nhưng mà nếu là sử trang
hay bị hack cho mọi bị thay đổi cái gì
đó thì đương nhiên là cũng đi à Như cái
này thì ra là nó nó thực ra nó không
biết được email của các bạn mà thì nên
là thức ăn nó lưu lại nó cũng 50 50
300 về Sam các thứ thì các bạn đúng là
phải xem cái bài này nữa bài không chỉ
đi cập về mỗi San đâu thêm xa là chưa đủ
đâu Nó không phải liên quan đến cả thêm
mà nên lưu hát ở đâu dùng hàm hát Tuy có
nên dùng paper paper không Đây chẳng hạn
thế Bạn đọc thử thấy nó chứng nghiệm rất
nhiều được
à à Nhưng mà cái này lắm chỉ những ông
biết tí rồi ông ấy lộc nha các bạn mới
học Quên Cái quý giá mà đọc cái thấy gọi
không hiểu đâu có thể đóng não lắm vì
lên mình mới đọc thì mình phải đọc ba
bốn lần mình mới hiểu ý
Ừ thì bé lý do mà bây giờ các bạn thấy
thực tế thì cứ thử thì nhiều nhiều trang
web vẫn chỉ nó còn cho vụ lại gửi chủ
tịch ạ oke TP gửi điện thoại hay gửi cần
phải cả mã gì cho nữa chứ bây giờ email
mật khẩu nó vẫn rất dễ bị lộ đúng Hồng
Vân Vân Vân Các bạn nên cài bằng một
thái lớp gì đấy không trừ của thằng
Facebook phải làm Facebook đôi khi Chính
Mekong cơ Mày không mò được không Nó hơi
bị
nó hơi bị kiểu
mạng Thủy nói chung mà cái bảo mật
Facebook kiểu hơi mấy rồi kìa ông có
thích sai nhưng bay đúng mà ẩm
thực tế thì nói về toàn ngược lại nó
giống như này này là đôi khi các bạn làm
khách hàng quá như thế liền hình các bạn
bắt thế mà nhập cắt ca rồi nhập bao
nhiêu thứ ấy mới vào được
cái đấy để bảo mật người dùng thì đúng
đấy nhưng mà người dùng cảm thấy rất bất
tiện người dùng khó chịu hoặc đoạn trích
ở lúc 10 người dùng bị hack hẳn nick
thật người dùng một tố cáo thì rất khó
thế nên mà nó 50 50 đó loa kiểu các bạn
khóa cửa thôi cũng thế thôi đúng không
cao bạn địa hình bây giờ các bạn đi ra
ngoài đường ăn uống ạ Các bạn cũng rất
ngại việc là phải khóa lạnh xe được các
dự thứ rồi Thậm chí của ông mang điện 34
hóa ra là khóa kèm theo còn trống các từ
từ nữa
nếu mà các bạn làm thế thì đương nhiên
là sẽ ra rất khó bị hack hơn khó bị
nhiều thì xe hơn đúng không Nhưng mà
cũng là nhược điểm cho các bạn đó chính
các bạn cũng mở ra là nhắm đúng không Ừ
cái này nó luôn là luôn là bài toán các
kiểu
anh khó cho các bạn thì khó luôn cho cả
ống trộm đúng không còn dễ cho các bạn
thì dễ cho cả trộn thì thôi Thế nên là
hồi trước mình đã từng thấy có một vài
ông còn chơi cho kịp để đỡ mất công ngồi
gõ lại mật khẩu Ông ấy cứ tạo một cái
trang đăng nhập Giả cái thằng hacker
thích khách gì hack ngoài trang đấy sống
lấy sử cái ảnh địa chỉ IP ông ấy đăng
nhập một phát vào luôn không cần Huệ
không cần phải bao nhiêu khi cả này cũng
là một cái
nhiều kiểu là ông ấy cửa chính của ông
ấy ở luôn khoái nhưng sự ông là khó ngay
cửa phụ nằm sau luôn mở đấy đâu Thế à
3 cách để lưu lại lịch sử ngắn trên bàn
phím như nào nó keylocker nhưng mà không
biết là các bạn tìm hiểu cái đấy điểm gì
có phải là đẹp mà thượng lưu lại
ngồi rà soát người yêu mình không
You are a good có bạn hôm trước cũng hỏi
vụ rocco vậy Oppo Mình nhớ không lầm
mình nhưng rõ Cô à à
à à
à À nó cũng lại ăn khuya hả Mình mình
chưa dùng cái này nếu mà mình nghĩ là nó
là atwell rồi thì tất cả mấy thằng cái
que để nào giống nhau cơ mà
à à
ừ ừ
Khi nào nào nào lại bảo say từng làm rồi
nhầm nhầm nhé Mình thì biết Nhiều cá
nhưng mình lại rất thịnh Mình rất thích
khách thậm chí thậm chí là mình có độc
với cả bên A gọi là cái này nói không
lại hơi Lặc điềm tình yêu mình cũng đọc
liên quan đến các bài toán về tâm lý học
các thứ thứ như mình cũng không đi hack
não người rồi cả mình không dùng cần
mình Susu socio Angeles để đi mỗi hack
Hay là thôi miên bất kỳ ai cả tôi cứ thế
mình mình nghĩ là làm mình cái đấy được
là nó hơi sai con người mình con người
mình ạ sống thật nhiều cao là
ở nhà ngày sắm cái này không sợ chết
đứng mình đưa cái Mạnh mồm là bởi vì
thực chất này mình không không sợ mình
làm gì sai cả không trả lương dân nhé
cho anh nhìn hồi bé Đi cũng mình từng kệ
vụ là mình cũng ạ trộm tiền mạng dien S2
á bỏ học để đi net hay Vân 2 Chỉ à
sao
không chờ mức dùng thì thảo là kệ tủ
khóa thì
kệ két sắt để mà đi lấy đồ của đồ trong
gì Trong đấy không biết nhưng mà
ở nhà mình cũng kiểu ở từng như thế thì
hồi này rất là dán cái kiểu cứ mỗi lần
về nhà sợ bị phát hiện cái thứ là
anh
nói chung là thực à kính người mà mình
thường anh nói dối nhiều nhất thì đôi
khi lại chính mình bởi vì mẹ mình đôi
khi ở quan tâm mình nhiều nên là mình
đôi khi ở nói dối mẹ ra cặp kiểu mình
vẫn ổn anh cứ với các mà mình cũng là
bệnh tật của các thứ chẳng hạn thế Ở
ngoài ra thì mình sống hay thảm
các bạn hỏi những cái vấn đề tế nhị yêu
khi bị sẽ dành trả lời thẳng luôn đấy à
à à
khi mình còn chưa vào một ít wenger chơi
mình có nghe qua đã thấy thôi cứ nghe
nói là nó lấy không dứt được nữa hơn
mình không làm nữa
Đúng rồi Thỉnh thoảng thì mình cũng khó
chơi cho ba cấp để mà để mà thuyết phục
hiệu trưởng làm vài cái gì đó như thực
là ông thầy vẫn tỉnh lắm ý
à à
em
chưa đổi hình như là chuẩn bị Visa cũng
thành hai tiếng mất rồi Chắc là các bạn
là tạm tạm dừng lại anh nhá
bài tập thì chắc là mình tớ bị đăng nha
Ok trả lời Yêu Nhé Tạm chào bạn nha à